and eric for more on this let's bring in
national border patrol council president
brandon judd brandon thank you so much
for being here today as you know this
week the biden harris administration
rolled out its strategies for addressing
the
root causes of the migration crisis in a
statement by the vice president i'll
read here quote
in central america the root causes of
migration run deep
and migration from the region has a
direct impact on the united states
in everything we do we must target our
efforts in those areas of highest
out migration and ensure that these
programs meet the highest standards
of accountability and effectiveness how
confident
are you that these strategies will be
effective
in slowing things down at the border i'm
not confident at all if you look at the
strategy it's it's very flowery
political speech that's all it is
there's no substance to it whatsoever
they talk about the
what but they don't talk about the how
they talk about what they want to
accomplish
but they don't give any any substance to
how they're actually going to do it they
talk about corruption inside of those
countries
they talk about the democratic process
inside of those countries they talk
about the rule of law inside those
countries
we don't have any authority in those
countries where we do have authority
and where we can make a difference is
right at our borders and if we would do
what we need to do
we could shut this off immediately we
saw that under president donald trump
this administration just will not do
what they need to do
to secure our border right now in real
time
and there's a tremendous amount of
frustration
by the folks who live on the border the
elected leaders who are there
on both sides of the political aisle for
example
our democratic republic or democratic
congressman from texas henry claire
let's take a listen
i've been very respectful very
supportive of the administration
but something has to change when it
comes to
border immigration issues on that
you heard about how hospitals are
overloaded as
mayor science said hey sometimes you
have to pit
a undocumented person that goes to a
hospital with somebody that lives in
laredo
or somewhere else i mean you know
there's limited spaces
the congressman hitting on the fact that
they have a two-fold crisis
actually happening at the same time you
have a 10-year high
in illegal border crossings down at the
southern border but then you also have
the covid crisis that continues
to spread down there and it just gets
worse every day
yeah the frustration is running deep
everywhere it's running deep within the
citizens
it's running deep within law enforcement
themselves i was out patrolling the
border just the other night
and and i'm sitting there wondering why
are we actually doing this if all we're
going to do is release these people
that cross the border illegally if we
continue to reward them
under the catch and release program
they're going to continue to come
we're not making a dent in in what needs
to be done we don't need more agents we
need good
policy and that's what this
administration is failing to give us
well and let's look at some of the root
cause strategies that they're talking
about here it includes
asking the private sector in the united
states and in other nations
to invest in these countries in honduras
el salvador and guatemala
additionally you have this multi-tiered
plan that includes combating corruption
promoting respect for human rights
promoting the free press
looking at the reasons behind it saying
that folks
who are fleeing their homes they're
coming here and they're trying to stop
this this seems like a
heavy lift for this administration
yeah it's a huge lift and it's just one
that's not going to happen in the number
of years that they have
this is something that would take 10 15
years
to actually accomplish the other thing
is how do you get private industry to
invest in these countries
where there is in fact so much
corruption where the the money isn't
going
to go into the hands of the right people
it's just an impossible task to do but
we can do it
right here on our borders where we need
to do it and the administration's not
doing it
they're not going to accomplish anything
they're going to give out this political
speech
hoping that it's going to appease people
going into 22 and 24. it's just not
going to happen
yeah and additionally um the the bite
administration is saying that they
inherited a problem that they
acknowledged that there were
um problems before the trump
administration but that the former
president made
things worse so they're looking down at
the root causes
um in the golden triangle and then
they're also looking at the previous
administration what about the
responsibility right now
yeah that's just not true what they
inherited was the most secure border
that we've ever seen
in my career 24 years in the border
patrol i've never seen
a more secure border we've never seen
the opportunity to go after the criminal
elements that are smuggling these people
in go
after the drugs that are coming into the
united states they inherited something
great they just
didn't build upon it they tore it down
yeah and this will just
continue um as we see those images that
bill mollusion and his crew down there
on the southern border were bringing
you think about the crowds of those
people and the coveted crisis
that is underway and and you said we
don't need more
more agents we need better policy but we
do need more agents too don't we
well we absolutely have to have more
agents in the field but policy is going
to give us that right now
we're starting every shift with at least
40 percent of our resources in
processing and by the end of the shift
we're up to 55
60 percent if we had good policy we
would be able to put our agents
on the line go after the criminal
element stop all of
all of what's happening and we can be
very very effective but we can't with
the policies that we're currently
dealing with
we will continue to watch this national
border patrol council president brandon
judd thank you so much for your time
today appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else